okay magnus
first of all thank you for uh for being
here for
answering some questions that we have
for you the first one is that you became
the world chess champion at the age of
22 years old how is the feeling to
achieve at the top of your sport at such
a young age
it was a great feeling of course
in that year 2013
most of my life was dedicated to that
particular goal of becoming
world champion but in terms of young age
in terms of overall age it was fairly
young but
in terms of chess age i'd already played
for many years and i felt like a
seasoned competitor
already
and you see now people
gaining grandmaster titles at
12 13 years old
so you really have to start where you
are
okay
after the world chess championship was
postponed in
2020 next month you will fight for the
title in dubai
how does a chess master prepare for this
tournament
there are different
levels to your preparation for a
wheelchair championship i would say that
the main
component is chess preparation it's
theoretical but it's also very important
with physical preparation to be
to be your best self in every way both
chest wise and physically
okay
you are now in the hotel royal highway
sancti petri in cadiz which are the
principal reasons
that makes this place the perfect
location to train for the world chess
championship
there are many good reasons to
to be here
first of all the weather is absolutely
beautiful not
too cold and
also
not too hot
so it's just it's also perfect for
activities
like sports like when we're playing
football we've been playing
uh paddle there's uh
there's there are beautiful gardens here
as well and also also good food so
it's really
a very
very good location to
to to prepare also it's important that
uh that the place in total is not too
big so that you can be concentrated on
the task
magnus inspired by the queen's gambit tv
show royal highway centipede has created
a unique chess experience
which are your thoughts on this tv show
and about fall
what did you like about metres gambit
that is our experience
um
first of all uh i i love the
the the tv show queen's queen's gambit i
thought the chess part was
really really well made with lots of
little
nuggets about chess and chess history
and game games that also i hadn't seen
before
as well as being a very
um interesting story that was well acted
i would say here um
i'm loving the fact that
the
hotel the resort they're innovating
thinking of something new i know that
spain is a country that has a great
tradition in chess a lot of people
love the game and in that sense it's um
it's a perfect combination oh thank you
how do you imagine the perfect place to
play chess
i would say um
perfect place to to play chess is
very close to to to here it's
a beautiful
beautiful garden with
no distractions
um what advice would you give to a
person who is starting
the art of chess yeah
i would say
for me personally what
always was the driver for me in chess is
that i found it to be fun and to be
interesting
and that has lasted to me
uh to to this day
so
um when you start out in chess be a
little bit patient because it doesn't
come out
it you don't you're not going to get
everything immediately
but after after that
um yeah do what is interesting do what
it do what is fun if it's just
wonderful because i think it's it's uh
it's a it's a beautiful transcendent
game but if it's something else
sure
in your case do you remember at what age
you discovered chess and how was their
way towards your your vocation and
professional career
i would say that i started um playing
chess i started learning the moves when
i was about
five and a half years old
uh and i kind of liked the game but i
didn't have the
the patience to like sit down and try
and study it to learn more so
i actually i would say that i started
learning more about chess when i was
eight i became really
interested first of all my first goal
was to beat my older sister
and after that
i just fell in love with with the game
and
i would always study study on my own and
i think it's been only one way since
and based on your own experience which
are the benefits of this sport for those
who practice it
i would say that
two
two things have been important for me
chess teaches you to think
analytically
and to be to be patient but i think it
also teaches you to make decisions under
pressure
and
in chess you're constantly under
pressure from
from time factors both on the board and
also on the clock and this you will find
to be
um
important in any
in any profession that you have to make
well calculated but sometimes also quick
uh decisions under under pressure and
this you learn perfectly from
and in which way do you expect this
final will be different from the last
championship in 2018 and 2020.
sorry 2016 16. um personally i'm hoping
that this time there will be
maybe fewer draws than there have been
in the last few
times
because
basically i have not led a world
championship match in
a classical chess since 2014 so the last
two matches have been really close i'm
really hoping that there will be a
little bit more uh back and forth
rather than a drawn out battle that it's
it's been the last few times so that is
my my hope and also my belief so
thank you very much
magnus that that was it so thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you